bon droit que ça y est la conférence des
développeurs d'apple a eu lieu et on
connaît les six grands points qui ont
été développés par la fille d'un dico
pour savoir effectivement quelle bourret
les nouveautés pour cette année 2010 est
en attendant effectivement la prochaine
keynote qui nous annoncera très
probablement le prochain iphone l'iphone
80 attendu maintenant tout de suite dans
cette vidéo on va développer un point en
particulier qui est extrêmement
intéressant et dans quel effectif on
peut parler parce que je l'ex et l'ios
11 alors un os qui était annoncé
effectivement comme je dirais une
continuité de ce qui se faisait avant
avec quelques quand même quelques
nouveautés phares un design qui était
légèrement retravaillé puis des
fonctionnalités qui ont été ajoutés on
va regarder ça directement parce que
j'ai la chance d'avoir cet os
directement dans mon téléphone
on va commencer par la fonction file qui
vous permet de retrouver vos fichiers
directement hop voilà donc là vous êtes
dans les fichiers vous avez les fichiers
sur le cloud sur votre iphone sur votre
iphone si vous regardez bon moi y'a rien
sur mon iphone mais sinon vous êtes vous
pouvez retrouver vos informations
officielles ça c'est par nom par date
par taille par tag vous pouvez
effectivement ce n'est des tags de
couleur pour je dirais faire des
catégories une catégorisation pour
retrouver plus facilement vos différents
types de données des données on peut se
retrouver sur votre claude c'est c'est
vraiment sympa c'est plutôt bien fait je
pense pour de du partage entre
différents appareils c permet d'avoir
accès à vos données à vos fichiers sans
avoir à les transférer à vous emmerder
c'est plutôt bien vu plutôt bien pensé à
mon avis autre point intéressant c'est
apple paie directement sur message
moi je n'ai pas de compte apple peux
donc pas vous montrer directement par
contre ce qui est très intéressant c'est
vous allez dans message vous ouvrez un
peu loupé et vous pouvez ouvrir la somme
exacte que vous souhaitez à votre votre
correspondance qui fait que si vous
devez par exemple 24 euros 50 55 ou ce
que vous voulez à quelqu'un vous envoyer
la somme sera pas la personne leur soit
sur son compte apple paix et peut soit
le garder sur l'apple peel pour payer
autre chose plus tard soit le retrait
sur son compte bancaire donc c'est vrai
que c'est plutôt bien pensé apple peut
exister pour les paiements aux
professionnels maintenant ces transferts
d'argent entre particuliers
c'est plutôt pas mal c'est plutôt une
bonne idée en tout cas notamment
retrouvé à distance on n'a pas toujours
la distance est difficile pour envoyer
de l'argent parfois envoyer des chèques
en faire des virements avec un peu pc
rapide et c'est en ça que c'est quand
même relativement pratique entrepôt qui
est vraiment cool c'est pour les lives
de photos alors là on va faire une
petite photo par exemple
hop je mate de votre côté 3 ma tronche
ça c'est moi et c c'est sa caméra
donc on va faire une photo alors à
tanger le bouger un petit peu pour qu'on
ait un truc qui bouge un peu voilà donc
la galerie photos quand je regardais ma
photo ensuite j'ai différentes
possibilités qui sont quand même
relativement sympa c'est à dire que je
vais pouvoir les dictée directement et
choisir quel parti je veux garder dans
ma life photo et qu'est ce qui va me
paraître être le le plus sympa bon bah
de mon côté il ya il n'y a pas grand
chose je peux dire que ça c'est la faute
aux principales je le définis en photo
principale elle parce que la photo qu'on
propose par défaut l'iphone os et pas
forcément celle qu'on veut donc là on
peut vraiment je dirais le choisir celle
qu'on veut et ça c'est ça c'est vraiment
cool
après il ya d'autres filtres qui existe
vous allez pouvoir effectivement va
changer un petit peu les couleurs de
votre image comme on peut le faire sur
instagram 1 sur toutes les applications
natives comme chat vous avez différentes
litres bon voilà rien de bien bien neuf
mais c'est cool que ça existe et autre
point qui est sympa si vous déplacez
votre auto légèrement vers le haut vous
avez ensuite les les effets d'animation
donc le live c'est la faute au live
classique la boucle qui va vous faire
une boucle effectivement bien sûr votre
sur votre photo en utilisant de la photo
bon vu ce qu'on a pris là il n'y a pas
grand intérêt mais si on utilise tout ça
peut être très sympa le côté avant
arrière je vais je reviens je revêts
refirent bon c'est rapidement une type
de tic mais c'est marrant et puis
ensuite on va voir la pause longue qui
est plutôt bien lorsqu'on l'utilisé film
et dénaturent de l'eau qui coule des
nuages enfin des choses comme ça ça fait
des effets qui sont très sympas là dans
ce cas là ça reste quand même assez
fantomatique tout en sachant qu'il ya
une nouvelle compression qui est
disponible sur sept est sur les photos
et sur les vidéos
de laïos 11 ce qui fait que vous allez
vous retrouver avec des photos et des
vidéos qui vont prendre ont beaucoup
moins de place donc plein de photos et
plein de vidéos en plus dans votre
appareil avec la même capacité de
stockage et ça il faut le reconnaître
c'est quand même plutôt pas mal autre
point intéressant ces messages dans
message via de nouvelles fonctionnalités
qui existent vous pouvez par exemple
envoyer des petits des petits quand vous
arrivez dans un message vous avez en bas
un petit dock qui vous permet
effectivement de reprendre les
différentes applications qui peuvent
interagir avec message on va penser
notamment à l'app store sur lequel vous
pouvez envoyer des applications qui vous
intéressent partager de la musique
directement sur apple apple musique sur
une appli qui s'appelle guillaume jan
blaschke partager des recettes
je peux partager je peux shazam et
envoyez la musique partager mon adresse
avec plan
envoyer des petits personnages rigolos
et en vous ferez de la musique que
j'écoute sur le figaro là par exemple il
ya plein de choses sur la politique sur
la campagne des législatives la campagne
présidentielle donc il ya pas mal de
deux petites choses de petites icônes
qui sont sympas que vous pouvez envoyer
un contact sa part n'est effectivement
je dirais d'abord un côté un peu plus
ludique au travers de messages donc
message gagner un petit peu à côté un
peu sympa et côté ludique si vous voulez
choisir
un nouvel effet vous pouvez sur les
écrans vous avez des nouveaux essais qui
sont ses vrais quand même sympa ça c'est
le projecteur bon les ballons là il ya
plein de choses qu'on connaît déjà les
confettis qui sont très sympas l'amour
avec un gros ballon le fameux laser qui
est toujours là le feu d'artifice voilà
bon il ya ce qui est vraiment original
est super sympa qui change un petit peu
ça va surtout être voilà le lait qu
envoyé avec l'écho et ça c'est vrai que
c'est c'est assez sympa entreprend sa
passe et l'app store qui fait peau neuve
l'app store qui a un contenu vraiment
très éditorialisé lorsque vous êtes sur
un partant de la section aujourd'hui
vous voyez un petit peu les nouveautés
les nouveautés d'aujourd'hui qui vous
parle d'une nouvelle app store des
applications
c'est vraiment très écrire vous avez des
conseils
vous avez tout un côté vraiment
éditorialisé avec avec des rédacteurs
qui doivent bosser
derrière ça pour vous présenter un peu
les nouveautés c'est plutôt bien fait
c'est vrai que c'est joli quand seront
le lieu assez bien c'est plutôt bien
foutu
autre point très sympa dans cette
section là vous avez effectivement la
party games vous présente tous les jeux
vidéo l'univers du jeu vidéo avec les
jeux du jour vraiment les jeux du moment
les jeux payants les jeux gratuits à
d'autres catégories se parler vraiment
de voir un peu quels sont les nouveaux
jeux dans ses jeux à découvrir donc ça
c'est pas mal pareil pour les
applications en règle générale on a le
même système toujours là ni un autre
jour la recherche ça ça ne change pas ça
reste la même chose syrie qui fait peau
neuve avec de nouvelles voies série qui
progresse toujours dans la logique du
diplôme ning c'est-à-dire
l'apprentissage de vos besoins
comprendre le contexte en prendre les
comprendre exactement quelles sont vos
recherches et puis à s'habituer
et puis comprendre vos habitudes de vie
pour proposer toujours des résultats au
plus près de ce que vous aimez au plus
près de vos goûts dont convoque syrie a
effectivement une voix masculine
une voix féminine une voix qui doit être
normalement plus fluide pour
effectivement mieux comprendre quelle
est la hauteur de la tour eiffel série
tour eiffel fait 324 mètres dos
ouais bon là la syntaxe est pas encore
sonné mais sinon c'est quand même pas
mal bon il ya un vrai progrès là-dessus
on pourra effectivement demander à siri
de vous traduire des phrases lorsque
vous serez dans un pays étranger vous
dira syrie sire que tu peux me traduire
ça permettra à votre interlocuteur qui
ne parlent pas votre langue de
comprendre ce que vous avez besoin de
lui dire donc ça c'est plutôt pas mal
c'est pas encore disponible en france et
tout de suite ça le deviendra
je l'espère très très rapidement parce
que le principe est vraiment bien on va
vraiment un qu'au niveau de
l'intelligence artificielle on va
vraiment sur le machine learning des
machines intelligentes d assistant
intelligent qui comprennent de plus en
plus qui vont plus en plus analysé vos
besoins dans les égouts style de vie
pour vous proposer quelque chose de très
très très personnalisé une avancée aussi
du point de vue apple musique alors j'ai
pas de compte apple musique donc je veux
juste vous en parler sans l'avoir essayé
de ce qu'on voit effectivement sur les
nouveautés d'apple musique c'est que
vous aurez encore plus de partage et
d'interactivité avec vos amis faire
découvrir une musique découvrir ce
qu'ils écoutent
bon on le retrouve très clairement chez
chez spotify c'est pas une grande
nouveauté mais c'est quand même plutôt
pas mal que effectivement un peu de
musique se mettre aller plus vers le
social là dessus autre point intéressant
c'est leur plaît 2 qui permet de
connecter plusieurs appareils et de
piloter plusieurs appareils notamment
avec l'homme pod qui vient de sortir qui
je dirais le diffuseur de musique pour
parler juste d'une seule grande
application de cette boîte parce qu'elle
fait plein de choses en réalité on en
parlé un petit peu plus tard cet homme
potes vous pouvez le collectif nous
pouvons en avoir plusieurs chez vous
dans différentes pièces les a signés et
les piloter avec naples et 2 et ça c'est
quand même plutôt bien fait le centre de
contrôle qui a été complètement revue où
on voit effectivement mais qu'il ya
plusieurs choses un entrepôt était plein
on peut complètement de personnaliser et
rajouter des fonctionnalités dessus je
vais dans l'ensemble de contrôler l'âge
peut rajouter plein plein plein de trucs
et si je rajoute tous ça va me faire un
espèce de centre de contrôle qui va être
juste énorme avec plein d'options dedans
ça c'est vrai que c'est plutôt pas mal
quand on veut activer désactiver des
choses à part des accès rapides ça vous
évite d'aller fouiller dans les
paramètres sont au coude droit le 3d
tête ça vous permet de faire quand même
pas mal pas mal de choses donc c'est
vrai que
sur le coup l'option est vraiment
vraiment agréable vraiment sympa et puis
surtout extrêmement pratique à utiliser
vous avez notamment une option qui est
en bas à gauche que moi j'ai rajouté qui
s'appelle ne pas le déranger lorsque je
conduis
ce qui fait que lorsque vous l'activez
et que ça reconnaît que vous êtes au
volant alors là ça ne marche pas
peut-être la version bêta qui encore des
petits blocs dessus lorsque vous êtes au
volant
ça permet effectivement de bloquer les
appels les notifications et tous les
messages les gens qui vous écrivent ou
qui vous appelle ça le rend un message
en disant je suis en train de conduire
tous leurs contacts après et lorsque
vous avez terminé de conduire ça vous
affiche tout ça et vous pouvez reprendre
contact et reprendre le fil de vos
informations et de votre actualité
directement sur votre téléphone
c'est ensemble que si quelqu'un vous
envoie un message urgent elle pourra
quand même ces personnes vous contacter
c'est quand même plutôt plutôt bien
pensé puis ça peut éviter pas mal
d'accidents sur le pont peut dire que
c'est quand même une bonne innovation
autre point intéressant c'est l'écran
verrouillé
lorsque votre écran est verrouillé hop
vous faites glisser vers le haut et vous
avez accès à vos notifications qui
s'appelle plus tôt dans la journée
et là vous avez tous vous avez vos
messages vos appels manqués vos emails
vos notifications de vos différentes
applications pour trouver tout un seul
et même endroit et on va le dire c'est
hyper bien il part bien fait bien
réfléchi et puis très intelligent de la
part d'apple d'avoir un peu centraliser
tout ça parce que avant fallait aller
sur la zone des notifications aller à
côté pour voir les messages mans que les
appels bouge donc faire tout est
centralisé et c'est bien fait bravo
autre mode qui est très intéressant dans
cette nouvelle version d'ios
on sait effectivement la possibilité de
mettre un mode sombre le dark mode
serez vous allez avoir tout votre foi en
noir et tout le reste qui va être écrit
en clair aux mêmes couleurs pour faire
c'est hyper simple vous allez dans
réglages général accessibilité ensuite
on va aller dans adapté l'affichage et
la inverser les couleurs alors là vous
avez deux versions soit une version
classique sous une aversion intelligente
si vous mettez la version classique ça
passe effectivement en dark mode par
contre tout ce que vous allez avoir en
termes de photos
être sombre et ça tout de suite à moins
d'abord une vision nocturne ceci montre
on doit reconnaître que c'est pas
terrible le mieux à ce moment là cette
semaine sur une inversion intelligente
et là c'est tout de suite beaucoup plus
sympa et surtout vos images sont
préservés alors après vous voyez un ce
système mais plutôt pas mal
il ya des choses qui sont pas terribles
un taxi vous allez par exemple dans
google maps tout de suite vous allez
avoir quelque chose qui va être très
très sombre et ça je dois reconnaître
que c'est pas génial génial c'est un peu
le point négatif si vous allez surfer
sur sur internet ça va être la même
chose tout va être sombre le fonds va
être sombre et tout de suite
alors autant il ya des choses qui sont
pas mal autant dès que vous allez
rechercher si par exemple je suis dans
google images et que je recherche des
images ça ne les affiche effectivement
notre sombre et ça c'est un petit peu
l'inconvénient autre inconvénient si
vous êtes sûr sur youtube vous allez
voir que tout le contenu va être
effectivement dark maul également donc
c'est tout de suite un petit peu un
petit peu tristounet ça s'est un peu
l'inconvénient sinon tout le reste est
vraiment vraiment sympa plancy qu'à
progresser alors j'ai pas tout trouver
directement j'ai cherché un petit peu
vous avez les plans intérieur qui
arrivent à l'aéroport jfk normalement
vous avez les plans intérieurs de
l'aéroport et plus seulement les plans
extérieur
donc ça c'est quand même plutôt pas mal
sur les centres commerciaux
effectivement ces annonces et pour avoir
la même fonctionnalité
voilà donc là j'ai été chercher jfk
directement je cherche voit la voyance
ou là je me retrouve avec les plans en
3d normalement tant que ça me sauve tout
2d 3d je peux le mettre en 2d ouais
c'est pas encore complètement ça je
pense qu'ils ont encore un peu de boulot
pour khartoum cartographier au mieux
mais dans l'idée vous allez vous
retrouver effectivement avec les plans
avec les différents niveaux avec toutes
les possibilités
des aéroports des grands centres
commerciaux ce qui fait que dans
l'absolu c'est quand même en principe
plutôt pas mal pour avoir encore plus
d'informations de plan pas uniquement
maintenant les routes comme quand
l'école n'a extérieur mais les bâtiments
publics où ses grands centres
commerciaux donc c'est quand même pas
mal tenu voilà un peu les grandes
nouveautés de cette es11
il ya aussi peu de nouveautés sur l'ipad
mais sans y développera un peu plus tard
quand on parlera de l'ipad qui est
annoncée cet ipad dispose 5-10 5 pouces
un style paltrow on a vu également que
la réalité augmentée est aussi de la
partie
aussi sur l'ipad mais avec ios 11 ça on
voit vraiment que c'est un virage qui
est en train de prendre apple elle est
vraiment sur la réalité augmentée
facebook va vraiment dessus que si c'est
un business et un marché qui est
vraiment en train de se développer pour
le jeu meilleur aussi d'autres
applications ça va être très intéressant
on va suivre ça de près je pense qu'au
final on peut dire que ios on s'est
quand même un os qui est plutôt bien
pensé avec de nouvelles fonctionnalités
alors rien bien d'un gain les
fonctionnalités bon c'est des petites
avancées il ya rien de bien bien
révolutionnaire le truc qui je dirais
qui est vraiment cool c'est de pouvoir
envoyer de l'argent directement ses amis
par message via apple paix ça c'est une
nouvelle avancée ça c'est vraiment cool
on va très bien qu'au niveau de leur
connectivité apple en avançant notamment
avec loeb pohdh que je vous présentais
très très très très bientôt
avec le mode on voit très bien que ben
on va pouvoir avec ce nouvel os 11
paramétrer plusieurs appareils
on va avancer également sur l'ipad
on va aller plus loin dans la réalité
augmentée enfin il ya pas mal de
nouvelles fonctionnalités qui avance
c'est une petite avancée un titre
personnel mais ça laisse en tout cas
entrevoir de nouvelles avancées qui vont
à mon avis être vraiment vraiment super
intéressante donc merci beaucoup d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à me
laisser des petits commentaires pour
nous dire effectivement ce que vous vous
tous vous en avez pensé de ce nouveau
eyeos 11 es ce que vous avez suivi la
présentation faite par tim cook et toute
son équipe
dites moi ce que vous en avez pensé ce
que vous retenez ce que vous aimez comme
principal point et on parle très très
très très très prochainement de l'homme
pod qui me paraît être aussi quelque
chose de très intéressant set fut pour
moi c'est la grande nouveauté
la grande nouveauté de cette
présentation c'est le mode parce que
effectivement parce qu'on est sur un
produit d'avenir
quelque chose un marché sur lequel il ya
une concurrence féroce en train de se
faire que ce soit entre google apple
amazon et d'autres grands du marché qui
vont bien dessus une concurrence sur la
dématérialisation des applications sur
le fait de ne plus avoir besoin
d'utiliser un ordinateur ou un téléphone
pour faire de la recherche pour de la
gestion globale de sa maison une gestion
globale de sa vie numérique entre
guillemets parce qu'on a encore besoin
pour facebook
je dirais 2
et d'autres applications d'un écran mais
ça risque de disparaître
il va y avoir beaucoup de choses qui
vont évoluer à l'avenir on va sur ce
traité parce que je pense que dans les
temps à venir dans les années à venir ça
va être de plus en plus intéressant
merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo n'hésitez
pas à mettre un très joli poussent vers
le haut si ça vous a plu vous abonner à
l'achat il y aura plein plein plein
d'infos sur la itech toujours plus
d'infos merci à très bientôt
je vous dis à très vite pour parler du
long-pot parce qu'il ya plein de choses
à dire dessus
ciao
[Musique]